hot breath awesome hi sarah it's nice to
meet you
yeah you too um so i'm like a
stand-up newbie um but i listen to your
album
at least like three times like i just
love it it's really
really awesome um and then i had a joke
like you talked a little bit about your
comedic voice
how would you personally describe your
um i guess maybe a little dry or
irreverent i try not to i try to make
fun of
both sides or like keep it even the
darker stuff
a little bit on the lighter side not
like a lecturing thing
because i just don't have the chops for
that to be
like a strong opinion and then have to
defend it
because i feel like you have to know
your subject matter and i only read
headlines in a little bit of the article
so i try not to
but i i guess anecdotal are things that
um
throughout your day-to-day life where
you're like why is this making me feel
weird and then try to figure out why
and like or your obsessive thoughts or
any weird
thinking that you have i think that's
how you get your point of view across
awesome um and then
how do you go about uh joking about
touchy subjects like religion
or something like without offending most
people
i know i never want to offend too much i
mean some comics love to but
um and they're if they're they're really
good at it uh
i again like i try to keep it like
as simple as possible and i also say
like
i do think saying things with the smile
or letting the audience know that you're
like
dude we're just here to have fun and
this is like
if you can't joke about the serious
stuff then i mean it just makes life a
lot easier than i don't know what
to say to you you know like yeah
that's how i try to treat it like i try
in my mind
i try not to give it weight like just
act like it's like if you're talking
about um
a subject matter that's dark or heavy or
maybe very personal
just treat it as if it's another a joke
about
um you know day-to-day observations or
something like that
like you don't care just push through
and this is what you're talking about
and don't give
anybody the way to make you feel bad
about it